in terms of the intelligence i talk a
lot about you know the differences
between intelligence and wisdom and how
wisdom is far more important than
intelligence when it comes to break that
down that's awesome essentially that you
know
a rocket scientist is intelligent there
are plenty of people who are very very
smart people but they lack no real life
experience or or type of wisdom for sure
politicians politicians you know well a
lot of them are very stupid too but
honestly
a lot of them are very stupid right and
so the wisdom comes from learning which
is what we talked about on the first
podcast where i said young boys need to
learn young boys need to fail all the
time they should be failing every single
year and learn from their mistakes and
learn from their mistakes it's the
number one thing in becoming a man and
wisdom comes when you're older there are
still old people out there who have no
wisdom it's not just something that
happens you have to fail and be willing
to fail and take risks to achieve
something great and that's where wisdom
comes in which is far more important
than intelligence well said from a wise
young man
[Music]